as the supervising sound editor I come
on earlier than Ron Ron is Ron's job is
to take the material that I'm going to
create all the sounds for the
Bladerunner University you've never
heard before I have to go through a many
months long process of designing and
creating sound you've never heard before
and then I give it to Ron later in the
process and his job is to take all those
elements and create a mix of that track
and I'll I'll use a metaphor my job if
you don't understand sound is my job is
more like the director of photography I
shoot all the little pieces of film but
of course you don't shoot those pieces
of film in order it's not a finished
film Ron is more like the editor he
takes all my pieces of sound and much
like the film editor crafts what the DP
gives him Ron takes all that timing
turns it into an actual soundtrack of
finished polished recording of audio
I'll give you an example the the
spinners which are which one of the
items we reprise from the first film the
the hover craft that Deckard flies in
those are made from bull roars you know
this is this cat-o'-nine-tails that
indigenous people spin above their heads
so a lot of the work that I do when I'm
designing is creating these free
associations and so I look I look for
kind of visual metaphor to find the
sonic metaphor so Theo green and I who
was my co sound designer we we started
looking for textures we wanted this kind
of buzzing spinning sound because they
were called spinners so I'm working with
something I was already given and we had
some recordings of indigenous peoples
doing this all we had was that simple
recording we then had to manipulate that
and turn it into the what sounded like
the engine of a futuristic spaceship so
you have to create sounds of it taking
off landing flying by inside the cockpit
steady state driving all from one sort
of little bit of of audio well tell me
what you did with those rumbles and the
rattling and all that how you
it's really cool Dimmie wanted to impart
this idea that the spinners because
we're post blackout this is a little bit
of story business everything there's no
more manufacturing there's no more spare
parts for anything so everything's in a
bit of disrepair so Kate and because K
is way down on the sort of totem pole in
terms of hierarchy of importance at the
LAPD he got a crappy spinner so he
wanted us to sell this idea of it not
working very well so one of the things
we did was we took a subwoofer for a big
bass speaker and we put it in my wife's
Honda Element an old sort of SUV kind of
vehicle and played low-frequency sounds
so that it vibrated the interior and you
would excite all the little parts that
are loose inside the car and you got
these great rattles so whenever you're
inside the spinner you hear the sound of
my wife's Honda not very futuristic what
a good rattle a lot of people say I want
that louder turn that down at 55 feet
turn this up and you're like okay do
that you know and it feels that way did
you manage yeah yeah Denis is very
different he looked from the heart he
would say in this scene I want K to feel
this and we're like ok so then it's up
to us they're like alright take these
down play more of this shape this
differently rebalance that is that what
you're looking for yeah the ability to
make that decision right and that's what
the freedom and the creativity that
collaborations is fantastic I love
working with people like that Denis is
very distinct in that traditionally what
we do which is called post-production
happens after the film is shot Denis is
a very forward-thinking filmmaker in
that he started sound when photography
started his thinking and this is
something this is this was fulfilling a
childhood dream for him he said all my
life as a filmmaker I've wanted to have
sound inform the Edit that's a very very
progressive idea and he put his money
where his mouth was and Theo green my
design partner started in the Edit room
with Joe Walker from the beginning of
photography the idea being that
sound is such a credits 50% of the
motion-picture should inform the way the
Edit is created from day one it should
be constantly informing such that by the
time photography is completed you have a
rough idea of the kind of the the movie
that you have they you know they're
obviously roughing in temporary music
the composer
although he's very prescient that way
due he had brought on our composer
during product during the shoot and so
all sound and image were all informing
each other to create the Edit fact that
concept really came into fruition where
there was a scene in the casino with
Elvis and that whole part where it's all
cutting in and out that scene was almost
cut out of the movie it's one of the
best scenes in the movie and the reason
it's back in a main reason not the only
one but the first concept was to have it
so chaotic that all of those musical
elements were playing all at the same
time it was total chaos and they were
running around trying to shoot each
other you know getting fight and it was
so chaotic
you lost the fight you didn't know what
it was about so they scrapped the whole
scene it was gone and then the music
editor Clint Bennett and Theo his
partner took it apart and started
cutting things in and out and changing
it up and had great dynamics of stuff
it's kind of broken it's 30 years later
nothing's been repaired same kind of
idea and it was magic because it allowed
so much you know anticipation and he
didn't know what was coming next and it
was so chaotic but in a very dynamic way
and and it turned back into a chase and
a fight and that's what he loved and
that scene got back in the movie another
critical relationship is between myself
and the composer as well as with Ron
definitely yes ow especially on a film
like this where we intentionally tried
to cross borders we wanted this to be a
seamless soundtrack where you couldn't
tell where score left off and sound
design began and vice-versa so we have
to learn to work very closely with the
composer to know that we're working
harmoniously that that's a really
critical relationship there was a lot of
that going
in this film more than anything I think
I've done and the way it was presented
at the first place was to deliver a lot
of different stems of the music separate
parts so you would have one sense four
stems
yes stems are like broken out parts of
an entire mix so if you hear the whole
cue it would be the sum total of all
these parts so every track is separated
I would have one synth track a different
scent track a low thing a pad and all
these things are separate then we would
go through and listen to them all and
they were purposely over built so that
we could then sculpt and change things
depending on what they've got going the
sound design the sounds that Denis likes
or does not like and we would go through
and pick stuff with Danny and he would
say I like that I like that I really
like that but not in my movie and we
take that out and try this and say that
was we had a plethora of great stuff to
work with from Ben and Han so you can't
go wrong with that but Denis would strip
things down and make it very simplistic
and then sometimes we build it back up
and it allowed you to be able to push
and pull with when sound effects came
and went and marry them a lot more
organically overlapping and trading off
where normally you wouldn't be able to
if it was all glued together and you're
stuck like get rid of that we're only
playing this it wasn't that way in this
film at all he knows like most smart
directors that he didn't he gave me a
cut of the film with no music in it and
he edits with Joe Walker that way
because he wants to know that a scene
works on its own merits before the music
bumps it up to that next level so his
thought was on this film we could work
very musically very compositionally not
diegetic ly meaning not put uh sound
because I see something on camera he
wanted us to work in these long sweeping
arcs much more like a painting much more
like an abstract painting and so Thea
was offered also a composer and I both
had this opportunity to create musical
textures which is kind of what we
extrapolated from the first movie it's
one of the successes of the first film
is that in any given scene in Deckard's
apartment
or in or in tyrell corporation-- an
environment is informed or infused with
these musical sounds but it's not melody
it's not rhythm
it's an ambience it's a musical ambience
that gives a feel to a scene so we got
to bring to bear all of our musical
abilities and in creating those sound
compositions that underpin almost every
scene in our movie so musical ability
was very important I think everybody on
our crew is a musician yeah come to
think of it
Byron the dialog editors guitar player
my partner Doug another guitar player
everybody drummer Malone percussionist
but that came in handy there was a scene
the Vegas walk we call it when he's
walking through the Red Desert going to
the bees and then the casino if we
backup before that we were mixing away
and Marc called me at night and says the
legal department called says we can't
use anything from the original Blade
Runner so we had spinner sounds we had
these giant drum hits you know the big
bow you know and we had to take all
those out so he says can you rerecord
some of those at home tonight I have a
home studio in 7:1 and I was like sure
I'd love to got out all my drums I'm
banging all these drums till 3:00 in the
morning my wife loves that part and
mixed the whole thing and brought them
into this studio the next morning and
remastered them all and then we start
placing him throughout the film and we
put some in that scene as well well
there's a huge music queue that goes
through the whole thing was always
planned that way and they wrote a
beautiful cue then he started stripping
it out saying what if we make it less
and more minimalistic and take that out
and take that out I got to think I'm
like Denis all I have left are the drum
hits he goes play it so we hit play we
all sat back we're like wow it was so
cool because it was so dynamic and so
anticipatory like what's gonna happen
he's where's he going and it was just
really dramatic and so we kept it and
that's how that ended up like that there
throughout the whole film is the first
sound you hear in the mood
so I was very proud of that and just
love the sound of like this huge drum
down to like not fairly any win and just
a few footsteps I'm particularly proud
of that sequence because from the time
cabe walks in the desert till he meets
Deckard it's a twelve minute stretch of
cinema with no dialogue and no music
almost unheard of in cinema and that's
that's a sign of sort of deniz bravery
in his filmmaking that he thought that
the imagery and the sound could could
carry the weight of the film without
exposition or music he inherently
understands that when an audience enters
a movie theater part of our job is to
what they call suspend disbelief we know
a movie is an artifice and it's the
filmmakers job to create a world to
invite you into a world and get you to
sign off on it to believe in it so part
of the success of that weaving of Sound
of Music and having you wonder which was
which is that subconsciously
we saw it as one soundtrack it's you
know soundtrack you hear that term
soundtrack is them you buy it at the you
know at the store that's the music of
the movie but sound is all the sound
that you hear and we tried to create
something that was much more seamless
than that such that the audience would
never be thinking ah music cue sound
effect
we just wanted sound this is the sound
of the Bladerunner universe I thought it
was very successful for us in creating
something you'd never experienced before
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]